hi I'm John castle I'm gonna be talking
about bioinformatics in the Wolfram
language we're gonna be looking about
how to bring in bioinformatics data both
from what Wolfram supplies internally
and also from external sources then
we'll look at all kinds of analysis
including sequence alignments sequence
motifs will be finding motifs and graphs
patterns of gene regulation networks
it's going to be great and take care hi
everybody good morning I'm John Castle
I'll be talking about bioinformatics in
the Wolfram language I work with the
Wolfram Alpha scientific content group
then decided to show you what we have so
a first I'll give kind of an
introduction then I'll show some of the
computable data that's built in to the
Wolfram language but it's not limited to
that we'll show you how to gather and
import external data then we'll turn to
analysis and analyzing sequences doing
sequence alignments sequence clustering
sequence motifs and then turn from
sequences to analyzing and modeling
interactions between different
biological components and then we'll
conclude so for all the purposes of this
talk bioinformatics is the process of
computing inferences about the structure
and functioning of biological components
using obtainable data in an integrated
way
so the we're going to give us just a
small survey of how existing Wolfram
language features help facilitate this
kind of bioinformatics where this is
gonna be a only cover really kind of
some basic about applications that
illustrate work basic functionality
rather than providing a comprehensive
workflow so there's a lot more that you
can do don't be fooled by this what's
here so just as a very brief biology
primer here we have DNA with its
characteristic double strand form the
interesting thing about it being that
these these pairs here can be kind of
substitute anywhere up and down the line
but once one of the pick one of these
residues is bound only the other another
kind of complementary residue can be
bound and thus this forms a kind of code
that allows a heritable information to
be passed on these this this brand here
then becomes the basis for containing
both the information that's translated
into proteins the workhorses of the cell
as well as operational information that
regulates whether or not the protein
created under different circumstances so
here we say so if the promoter is bound
then this DNA is kind of read from here
into 2 reading frames they're
transcribed into RNA which then have
these sequences here for binding to the
ribosome which actually do the work of
taking amino acid sequences together and
turning them into into proteins so they
I guess there are two kinds of sequences
available to do analysis on here a kind
of DNA sequences and the protein
sequences that are generated as a result
so there's a lot of computable data for
this kind of information in Wolfram
Alpha first we can get overviews with
this double equals commands so here
we're going to be looking at mus 81 this
is a gene that as that when expresses
the protein can repair a particular form
of damage that happens during DNA
replication so here we see that we have
its name other names where we find it on
the gene its reference sequence nearby
genes what part of the sequences are
actually used in building the protein
molecular weights and the functions that
the gene performs so here we see DNA
repair a part of DNA recombination this
is the gene ontology tactics anomie is a
really well-built ontology for
characterizing cellular activity very
specifically here we see a comparison to
how this gene expresses itself in the
sequences of different organisms what
part of the sequence are actually used
within the protein and so forth now we
also are not limited to sequences that
are already necessarily specified but we
can take sequences in and determine what
amino acids there there consists of and
find where on the human reference genome
they occur and how that compares to the
number that you would expect
if they were if the they were randomly
available across the genome now once you
have the gene and it's translated into
the protein we also have some
information about that including the
reference sequence and what their weight
and and this kind of thing and not only
do we have information about these
sequences we also have some information
about processes such as metabolic
pathways the processes by which food and
fuel are converted into the structured
energy of biological systems here's the
TCA cycle one of the most important and
well conserved cycles in our biology now
let's see here there we go okay now now
once you've got an overview of what you
might like to look at you can actually
dig into that with entities enemies
provide a consistent experience the by
giving a uniform way to get our data so
here's the must 81 gene as an entity and
then we go through and use the enemy
value display all these as a dataset we
see we have the gene length and the
molecular function names and all the
good stuff that's available and what
from Alpha is now available here in
computable form proteins similarly you
have a named protein you can hook it up
gather information about there including
its domains and where it appears now
must 81 I'm just using a demonstration
not very popular protein econo tastes
extremely popular protein cures and like
you know the TCA cycle so we have even
more information about it we have the
chain labels and we have secondary
structure information and diagrams about
it let's look at those diagrams a bit
more so here it comes in and that's okay
but let's blow this up with by importing
it and so we have this structure here
and we see that we we have a lot of
these alpha helixes and beta sheets two
different kinds of structure and sure
enough we can tell you where along the
the protein sequence that's
sure can be found we also provide snips
these are single nucleotide
polymorphisms these are the kind of
differences between the reference genome
and population data and this is really
useful for things like the 23andme
analysis and this kind of thing as these
are where traits diseases heritage and
evolutionary history can frequently be
tracked so a third way of getting the
even more computable data is we have
provides some specific data functions
for these such as genome data so it's
much of the same information but back in
kind of a different form kind of a maybe
a lower-level form although something
else that's here is genome lookup so if
you have a particular sequence you'd
like to find compute ibly then you can
find where along the chromosomes these
occur and we see that that that lines up
and protein data also available and in
this form so I guess we have a lot of
what the reference data but if you're
really going to experimental data or
other broad sources you really want to
get out there and gather like you know
or whatever experimental data is
important to like your particular
application so the NCBI entrez a utility
z' is really kind of a major suite for
getting access to all of ncbi National
Center for Biotechnology informations
databases they've done a great job in
making them uniform and we've provided a
variety of resource functions for
accessing the different services that
are available as from NCBI so info we
kind of get the databases and then we
see can see like the schema for those
databases so here we see in the gene
database there's a among other things
the gene name field so that'll be handy
for us later now we look to are looking
at AG query which gives the count of
records for each term in HN
see I database so we look for our old
friend must 81 and sure enough we find
it has a good number of records inside
of the gene database oh yeah you we can
what see here so yeah
because I'm showing a lot I'm not
valuing things as I'm going through just
for the expedite thing but sure enough
it all did work at one time and which
would work in the future so now that we
have a search so given that we have the
gene database the gene field look for
mus 81 and we do have a number of
Records here for each of those records
we can use the e summary service to get
a summary of what's in there and then
for use there a fetch to really go deep
into into what the structure is here
looking at which parts of the sequence
are actually expressed in the protein
now little service that they provide is
actually biological spelling correction
so here I misspelled mitochondrial yeah
but here it's fine and there's a lot
more information about this including an
appendix to these slides so other data
sources PDB we saw it before we'll see
it again it's really great well
supported here one thing that nice is
also the European bioinformatics
Institute the year being equivalent to
the NCBI really has extensive sources
and they provide them all in rest api's
which is great so you just Earl execute
you get it as JSON and then you put it
in datasets and all across their their
platform it's all kind of really uniform
and quite nice so now that you've got
some data it might be in a particular
format that you prefer not to wrangle
yourself but having a nice computable
form so GenBank is a standard for
exchanging annotated DNA sequences and
here we have an example of pulling that
structure out now even here's something
that's nice using the NCBI services we
fetch one
we find that there's you know they
didn't include a standard element in
there but even then we still can recover
all the structure that we we need so
these services are pretty robust even to
if they chip it's something that where
they choose to leave some data out FASTA
also a standard for exchanging DNA and
protein sequences so this on the FASTA
pull out the headers pull out the
sequences no problem
PDB as we saw before we can get into the
structure of pdb files get those back in
a nice data set and we have a variety of
other sources for these are for micro
arrays and pyrosequencing and things
that really have an earlier in the
experimental process should you need
that alright now that we're past all the
data importing we can get on to analysis
which is it's always my favorite part so
here just as a quick toy example to
introduce sequence alignment so here we
see 80 is the same then they and GG
differ between the two and C is the same
so if you see these in the future that's
what's going on now looking at a may T 1
or M 1 which we see that in we have data
for humans
nice rats and chimpanzees so we're going
to go ahead and compare those for the
purpose of this alignment and so we have
we gather the m1 gene entities for each
of those we gather the reference
sequences for each of those and now we
so we have our data now to do this
alignment comparisons we're going to be
using the smith-waterman similarity
which is the standard local similarity
score for this work unfortunately that
is not normalized so depending on the
sequence the length of the sequence your
results can can vary so we'll normalize
that and we'll also create a distance
metric that's the inverse so the smaller
the the closer together they are the
more similar they are now if we all
we perform sequence alignment on mice
and rats we find that it's pretty it's
pretty choppy the alignment isn't
necessarily that great there are a lot
of sequences that they don't share well
humans and chimpanzees seem to share a
lot looking at the beginning of the
sequence alignment but if we look at
here we see at the beginning of the
sequence they share quite a bit well
later on it doesn't look like the
alignment is quite so great so it's the
jury still out so let's let's do some
clustering to see how alike they
actually are and computing the
similarity ratio across all of them we
find that actually it does line up quite
well we have a cluster the clusters for
between human cheese and rats nice seen
here see how these are kind of taller
than store the base line and that the
cluster density is also where we would
think now so sequence alignment doesn't
necessarily tell us what parts of the
the sequence are really the working
parts of the gene the parts that are
going to be conserved across evolution
to do what the what the gene is actually
supposed to do so now we're going to
extract some motifs or kind of common
sequences that are between them so I'm
working from this paper we we're going
to be comparing a yeast fruit flies mice
and humans using the tools we gathered
before of a search and efetch we gather
each of these sequences now we're gonna
just do a very quick and dirty thing
where we're going to find the longest
common sequence shared between all of
those sequences and then align each of
the each of the sequences to that common
sequence and when we do that and using
this underscore to indicate only a
single character difference we find
these local motif locks
that if we transpose together and find
the minimum of we find this this one
right here which matches kind of the
reference comparison we were so even
with doing something very very simple we
were able to extract the better part of
the kind of the key motif for this
protein if you want to do something more
sophisticated then what there are so
many great algorithms out there yep
so we have in this case the European
bioinformatics Institute offers about
you know eight different clustering
techniques will choose clustal Omega
which is kind of a standard
middle-of-the-road choice and using
their web service and processing their
results we still find that we get back
to where we where we wanted the Iver vdl
sequence so vile informatics is not only
great for understanding the
functionality of particular biological
structures but it is also great for
understanding interactions and this is
for kinda really exciting topic here now
this is the regulatory network of e.coli
and where the red arrows are activating
and the blue arrows are inhibitory and
so what this looks fairly complicated we
see a lot of negative self inhibitions
which seems curious that a gene would
turn itself off so what's let's see if
that's actually is a thing and what it's
about
so what let's compare the number of
times that occurs in our set in the data
set versus what we'd expect at random so
the number of self regulators that occur
is 59 the number that we'd expect at
random is 1.2 so that's we have about 46
standard deviations more than we would
expect by randomest alone
so so what's happening here so suppose
we model the concentration as as this
production rate we're going to assume
mRNA and production degradation they
happen too fast for this process of
they're in quasi steady state
degradation is too slow so it's
negligible and we end up with with this
curve here and now if we add an auto
regulation term with with this Sigma
what we see is that we get a good burst
straightaway that tapers off with a with
a transcription factor binding of about
1/3 and so what this means is is that
you can for these genes it's important
for them to be activated right away as
soon as they get the signal they're
often running and producing a lot of
proteins but then then tapering off
sooner so that you know they're not over
produced so you can tell that the if
something is negatively auger it
negatively Auto regulating it's
important that it gets activated kind of
like you know right away that it really
responds to its environment now that was
a kind of interest thing but what let's
see if we can discover something that we
couldn't necessarily see in amongst
ourselves so we're gonna look at all the
three node interactions so here we
isolate all the subgraphs of the three
interconnected nodes here and then we
gathered them into isomorphic groups so
this is this is kind of neat just by
saying a a front for each edge pair
group for its graph find the first
isomorphic roof that's that's that's
like it if we don't find one it's a new
group otherwise append it to its
existing group and we find that here
that the only three node isomorphic set
that isn't just two edges is this this
pattern here this feed-forward pattern
where there's an edge connecting to the
end and there's one happening in the
middle so are these things
Kent and so there are 126 of them and we
expect at random about 1.9 yes oh yes
that's there's like you know sixty-four
times like standard deviations more than
we would have otherwise so what's going
on with the dynamics here so we'll go
ahead and find the most common dynamics
by removing the labels from the graph
and then and then tallying them and we
find that this all activation path is
the most the most common and so this is
this is kind of coherent dynamics
there's nothing's inhibiting is all
activating and what happens here is that
if both if Z depends on both oh it's a
here I'll show this graph here up here
if Z depends on both X and Y then if Z
starts here and then Y starts a bit a
bit less depends on Z then Z is very
slow to respond to initial
concentrations of X and what would this
what this means biologically is that we
really want to be careful that Z has to
respond to X but X can get turned on and
off for a little bit it can be noisy and
it's really important that we don't have
that much that much Z until you know
it's really really sure that that you
know X is on and it's going to stay on
so what we didn't cover we didn't talk
about system modeler we didn't talk
about biochemistry data didn't talk
about hidden Markov models any number of
other topics that we have in the Wolfram
language so as a result we see that the
Wolfram language support for
bioinformatics is very broad you know
data gathering analysis modeling
visualization but it's not comprehensive
I mean there's so many more data format
so many more sources so many analysis
things that we can add so really what
world with the new directions you know
we're always interested in feedback for
which you know
which we can person we want to pursue
what our collaborators can pursue and so
really be interested in hearing about
that